um so speaking of crazy behavior this C
oh gosh I this is T okay this is T okay
you know Candace Owens works for Ben
Shapiro at the daily wire I do now we
all know there's this huge conflict
going on in Israel right now now me
personally I haven't really I I don't
know enough like the conflict is so
confusing to me that I don't really I
think it is to a lot of people yeah I I
don't really have a side right I could
see both points of view from what I've
heard mhm but I don't know I'm not I I
that conflict is very confusing well
it's been it's a conflict that's been
going on for thousands of years so I
don't think anyone really knows what to
make of it exactly there's some obvious
things that we can all take from it but
there's also a lot that I don't think
any of us will ever be able to
understand because it's been going on
for so long yeah and what I've heard
Candace Owens speak out about being
called anti-semetic okay because they're
basically lab labeling Candace as
anti-semetic now I have a little bit of
experience
I found out yesterday the most Googled
I've ever been yeah was when I was
called anti-semitic no but it's so
interesting because I don't even have an
opinion on that stuff like I don't even
have a strong feeling one way or the
other I could listen to someone on both
sides talk and I would understand where
they were coming from as of now and yet
I got labeled anti I was like wow what
what the hell so I I heard Candace
saying that she condemns genocide on
Twitter I know she had a clip of her
talking about how she wanted to nominate
Nikki Haley for the president of Israel
and um she's sort of been poking fun at
people calling everyone and everything
anti-semitic and I we're going to go
through some of these now there's a clip
that came out of Ben Shapiro slamming
Candace Owens for her absolutely
disgraceful behavior in front of a
visibly shocked audience Shapiro goes on
to say her Fox sophistication on this
issue is ridiculous tensions rising at
the daily
wire yes
the question was about Candace ens I
think her behavior during this is well
without
[Applause]
doubt yeah she works my company I think
she's been absolutely disgraceful I
think I think that her her F
sophistication on these particular
issues has been ridiculous it's not F
sophistication it's ridiculous everybody
can see the moves that she's making and
the things that she's saying and
iable what is her Behavior what's he
referring to so there's a video here is
one example of what Candace has been
saying in the recent weeks Owens
endorses Nikki Haley for president of
Israel amid collapsing support for
Jewish State well I am here today to
endorse Nikki Haley for president of
Israel I think she's earned that I think
BB Netanyahu is going through a very bad
time right now support for Israel has
virtually collapsed socially if you're
paying attention to the trends and
you're paying attention to what people
are watching you're paying attention to
the protests and the one person that I
think is capable of getting it back is
Nikki Haley with enough money from
foreign interest lobbies so there it is
guys I'm endorsing Nikki Haley president
of Israel so Nikki Haley Nikki Haley is
a presidential candidate in the US okay
um she worked for the UN a couple of
years ago I actually met her I actually
met her a couple years ago really quick
selfie I personally don't think women
should really be in positions of power
like that so I'm not the biggest fan
I've kind of seen her the little takes
that I've seen of hers I don't really
like like she had one take that everyone
on social media needs to have a public
account that that seems like tyranny I
think you have I don't enjoy the trolls
you guys annoy me but I I will say you
have the right to have an anonymous
account with no pictures I'm not but
like you know that kind of goes back to
how women like to micromanage and Etc
and I think she's had a lot of pro warar
stand es okay and so basically getting
more involved in the Israel Palestine
conflict that's what Nikki nikk Haley
yeah and so I want to say I think she
has that view of Nikki Haley because
Nikki wants to get more involved I think
Candice thinks we should stay out of it
based on what I've seen um there's three
stances that I've seen I've seen people
that are on the side of Israel that we
should get involved and support Israel
I've seen people that are on the side of
pal that they're saying we should get
involved and support Palestine and I've
seen people that think we should just
stay out of it so um Owens compares the
media's recent outcry over anti-Semitism
to their complete silence on anti-white
racism what makes the Jews so special
let's pull it up we had a similar thing
happen here in the UK very very recently
our um Home Secretary was sacked for she
pointed out that the police in the UK
were quite harsh on the um British
protesters I don't really know exactly
the the context of what was happening
but the police were harsh on the British
protesters and a lot of people were
saying that this Suella bravoman lady
spoke for the sort of quiet majority of
British people I don't know I don't know
enough about her to say whether she
speaks for me or not but what I do know
is that we are seeing a lot of people
talking about how come you can speak
about anti something anti something but
you can't talk about this well I had a
song dedicated to just that
and yeah that
backfire anyways um let's pull up the
video there are a lot of people in
America that are sitting here going okay
well can you answer why Jews are so
special because as white people in this
country on University campuses we are
being taught that we are not allowed to
have a voice we have had to endure
exactly what you're talking about BLM
we've endured much worse than you have
because it's in the actual textbooks we
are being told that we are
systematically racist that we are born
wrong because of the color of our skin
and if we say anything we'll lose
everything this is the typical
experience on white camp is so people
this is not what about is and this is
like actually what we have been fighting
for years so it sort of arrived as I
think for a lot of Americans a surprise
when they're saying well now that it's
about Israel which is something that's
overseas we need to you know hand these
University professors we need to do
something about this issue why weren't
we trying to correct course on this
issue why weren't donors pulling their
funding out of these universities why
weren't these same things being said for
these last I would say eight years of
rampant BL
white man can't do anything right
actively being taught in the classrooms
so there are people that are asking that
question now what I have said is that
explicit calls for genocide which was
stunning to me to see that in in in
Congress are completely wrong it is
frankly crazy I have not weighed in on
the idf's response in the same way that
I I have consistently said through every
war Ukraine and Russia I don't want to
be involved I have said I don't want to
be involved in Israel and Palestine all
these conflicts my consistency seems to
affect offend people right but I haven't
made a single tweet or a single comment
on idf's response in Palestine I haven't
said a single thing about that I have
said it is always sad when a child dies
and the lack of humanity that I have
seen from both sides has been very
troubling for me but to say that I have
have to weigh in and suddenly be be you
know wave an Israeli flag and say things
that you know be because you decide that
you get to use my platform because it's
personal to you how is that fair to
people how is that fair and then to then
go a step further and to suggest that it
might be anti-semitic which is basically
silence is violence as a leftist tactic
to me feels very extreme this is not
about a geographical geopolitical
dispute between Israel and Palestine
this is about an ideological mission to
rid the world of Israel and and the Jews
that's what I think people misunderstand
yeah well I what Jews live very
comfortably in the United States of
America so they're not going to be I
mean it you know obviously Jew they
lived comfortably in Germany before
I
did struggle I really struggle when
people start using you know things that
have happened in the past that are
boring like slavery to say that like if
this doesn't happen then slavery is
going to be back or if this doesn't
happen then it's going to be the
Holocaust too I think there's a lot more
meaningful chatter and discussion that
we can have we don't have to resort to
that kind of you know history repeats
itself if you forget it you know you
have to be conscious and Jews especially
unfortunately I I'm a grandchild of all
four my grandparents are Holocaust
Survivors so what do you of the
Holocaust Survivors and the Jewish
people in New York City that are
protesting on behalf of
Palestine that's a great question I
think yeah I think that there's a very
strange bizarre um I mean it's the same
people that you would condemn as the
people of the white people who bowed
down to BLM protesters who hate
themselves and feel a certain sense of
guilt they feel a certain sense of I
think a lot of the ideologies on the
woke left to the extent that things are
good and prosperous and virtuous they
condemn as bad and the things that are
broken morally and depraved they see as
good this is the lens by which the
far-left views things and I think these
Jews that happen to be politically farle
and maybe are not that connected to
their Judaism or are culturally maybe
culturally Jewish but don't have a
strong Jewish upbringing not to say that
politics and being a Jew go hand inand
with the same political identity but my
point is just like those the the white
people who in in Mass on were were
bowing down and feeling guilty about
themselves simply for being white or
people who feel guilty for being
successful or the anti- capitalists who
say anyone who has something is
necessarily bad some people buy into
that sort of masochism of hating
themselves and to gain favor with people
who want their destruction it's really
sick so would so would you say that in
order to be a Christian you have to a
Catholic you have to support the Vatican
like you can't be a a je a Jewish person
that doesn't just doesn't support the
state of Israel is that what you're
implying yeah because I have Jewish
friends that are pro-israel and I have
Jewish friends that say that they are
they just do not support Zionism at all
and that they think that the creation of
the Israel state is something that is
political and has nothing to do with
actually the Jewish faith at all and so
I listen to both of those sides I try to
hear both of those voices and I don't
think having a different perspectiv
makes any person less Jewish and I think
it's been problematic to hear and this
is not you this isn't a criticism toward
you when they say well to even have that
perspective makes you not Jewish because
it's so remniscent for me of me saying
I'm a black conservative and they say
well even to be a black Republican it's
it's you know of course so I didn't see
anything anti-semitic or hateful oh was
is that what they're saying is
anti-Semitic I mean I I don't know what
Ben shipiro was referring to as this
terrible Behavior because to me it's her
exploring the idea she doesn't sound
like she's saying she's an expert on the
topic she doesn't sound like she's even
really taking aside um she kind of seems
similar to me where we're both like
don't know what to make of it so let me
learn about it and maybe she's a little
bit like like she probably is a little
bit like knows a little bit more but I'm
like I didn't even see her go hard one
way or the other um some of Owen's
recent likes okay let's
see Zionist Lobby is starting to go
after Candace Owens now she will learn
cernovich says by now it's clear Israel
is indiscriminately bombing Palestine
it's a lie to say otherwise you can say
it's necessary that's a matter of moral
judgment and opinion but please don't
lie
oh she liked this one that said I don't
know frankly who should control Gaza
when or if Hamas is wiped out but I do
know it can't be Ben
Benjamin notah thank
you Pierce Pierce Morgan criticizes the
Israeli Israeli Prime Minister's plans
to occupy Gaza after the bombing is done
one must wonder if Ben Shapiro feels
similarly about Matt Walsh who has been
similarly outspoken about Israel first
zionists following the GOP primaries
debate last week he said Republicans
allegiance to Israel is a mental
sickness this is not how people talk
about their own
countries this is a uniquely modern
American phenomenon it's like a sickness
a mental sickness where some of our
leaders or would be leaders profess
greater admiration and love for and
pride in foreign countries than their
own it's just a crazy thing to say again
Matt Walsh slammed Nikki Haley for
contradicting herself in last week's
debate Haley demands that the US help
Israel but just moments later claims
that Israel doesn't need the us at all
funny enough this seems to Echo a
similar contradiction from Shapiro last
month Israel doesn't need us we need
them if that's true then how can you say
that in one breath and then in the next
breath tell us that it is imperative for
the United States to help Israel I
thought you said they don't need us they
don't need us at all we could not exist
according to you and it wouldn't make a
difference you you cannot say both of
those things you cannot say they
desperately need us and also they don't
need us you really expect us to believe
that America benefits more from its
Alliance than Israel
benefits from that same Alliance that is
nonsense no Israel greatly benefits from
America they say that I want America to
fight Wars for Israel nope nope first of
all Israel can take care of
herself if Israel is forced to the wall
the possibility of nuclear exchange is
extremely high that is why it is very
important that the United States provide
the material Aid to
Israel and that they also dissuade heah
from
Wow there is a lot going on at the daily
wire can you imagine if this was a
network so you have all four people like
tweeting about each
other and now
oh are they do you think they're going
to fire Owens no you don't think so no I
think they will I think she'll either
leave or they'll fire her I think she
will leave she'll leave leave but
they'll oh like publicly she'll leave
but really she got fired I don't think
Walsh will leave though how have Walsh
and Owens not been fired from the daily
liar
yet guys come and join the audacity
Network guys guys look I have a I heard
I heard Candace's husbands from England
I mean we're right Candice look it this
desk right here is
free like we have a slot for you
look okay Matt and Candace are about to
get sacked yeah Matt look it we're in
the UK look it I know we had our the
weather's not great but you know we the
weather's quite bad Big Ben London I
yeah look it look Ben's about to have a
mass firing it's got to be interesting
in having I I I understand you need to
be somewhat ideologically aligned if
you're going to be part of the same
network but it kind of begs the question
of what can you differ on and what can't
you yeah because that's such that's got
to be such a big and like personal issue
to Ben Shapiro that I am surprised they
like worked for him to begin with
because that seems to be like a core
issue of who he is yeah so I'm actually
surprised he had them at all well maybe
because it when they joined it wasn't
that big at the time no so now things
are coming to the Forefront emotions are
playing probably a bigger part and
things are coming a bit more evident to
people how they feel about certain
things and therefore maybe it's
revealing certain ideologies and things
that they have I don't think it was
disgraceful Behavior though I I did not
see anything from Candice that was
absolutely disgraceful Behavior I think
it's a to me what I'm I what comes to
mind for me is in the book 1984 the idea
of thought police and
unfortunately I'm seeing this pattern in
the media across all sources right now
if you ask questions you're
automatically given a label
of
disgraceful why can't
sorry see how careful we're having to be
like know I know and that's the that's
the thing and it's like then it makes
you question what and then it's like we
when you have thought police and you
were prohibiting people from asking
questions because what I have seen from
Candice with my own eyes and ears this
is all I've seen with this dispute I
have come to the conclusion that she was
not acting disgracefully in fact she was
acting she was acting curiously and
perhaps in certain areas when she was
referring to the anti- whiteness she was
playing a devil's advocate now her
intentions we can't know we're not
inside Candace's head no one is so we
can't infer what we think she's doing
but what I do think Beno is doing in his
statement that he made is inferring that
he knows Candace's intentions and I've
seen this pattern in every single
conversation on this conflict I do see
the same pattern where people label you
something for asking questions and that
begs the question why can't we ask
questions because Society collapses when
we stop talking to each other we stop
asking questions well and I think it
makes it worse because it makes one side
seem suspicious because nobody can say
anything to them and so people that are
in the middle are kind of like what
what's going on um but you know I I
don't wish that they break up I think
Matt Walsh will stay I think Candace
Owens will leave I think she'll either
quit or they'll fire her she yeah